I discover this subject of abayya,
I tell you frankly,
I discovered it by uh.
The art of the political media magician who has
put this subject on the table that exists
in places,
I get it,
150 of the 60,000 establishments,
there was 1 political debate,
there have never been any decisions made,
no teacher has ever brought you up.
I assure you that I have not been
seized on this issue.
So for you anyway,
you would not have made the priority?
High school students without an assignment,
hours for our college students
and uh,
children who are disabled,
that have no solution,
what are parents telling me today?
That's what parents tell me,
uh
when they do not have a business for the alternation
or learning,
today,
Parents only talk to me about this and the start of the school year,
just on purchasing power.